Basically, I do have um Muslim friends
that ask me questions that sometimes I
can't answer.
>> That's that happens. We grow. That's how
I grew. When the Muslims ask me
questions, I grew and here I am today. A
miserable, angry old man. But go ahead.
What's the question?
>> Uh so there's two um
there's two passage. one of the passage
I think it's uh Mark
>> 11 verse
>> oh I can't remember now
>> but he was asking about the uh
>> the tree not knowing the season or
something
>> yeah fig tree
>> it wasn't season for figs okay so what's
his problem with it
>> he said he basically he's asking if
Jesus is God how
why doesn't he not know the season of
the tree
>> who told him that Jesus being God was
aware it wouldn't produce figs. But I
have an answer for that. But I first
I'll say, who told you that Christ being
God knows it will produce figs
and that's why he cursed it? Just
because it's not the season for figs,
does God know before the season whether
a tree will be fruitful or not?
>> Yeah.
So, how is that an argument against
Christ when Christ is coming to the tree
and as God knows that tree is dead and
won't produce figs in season? That's an
argument against him, not for him. So,
God has to wait for figs to pop out on a
tree to know that this tree is dead.
>> I'm confused by the answer. Even a
hungry Jesus can he come to a tree and
as God know that tree is dead and won't
produce figs.
Fig trees produce something called tak
appears right before the figs
come out. Those t called knobs is what
people eat. And when you see tak and
knobs on that fig tree, then you know
it's good. and that figs are about to
come out of that tree. Okay, you get you
get it now?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
>> So, I know the objection. I know the
answer. But I'm asking you to think more
deeply. Even if Jesus comes as a man
hungry looking for something to eat,
could he not know as God this tree is
dead?
>> Yeah, of course. Yeah.
>> Okay. But put that aside because they'll
say, "Well, why then look for something
to eat?" This is happening in the spring
season when they're about to have their
harvest. And anyone who knows anything
about figs in that area would tell you
that a fig tree will produce what's
called tak tiny knobs that are edible to
eat. And if there are no t no knobs,
that means it's dead. So Jesus knew what
he was looking for. He was looking for
the t. Let's go and read it. See the
article I just gave you the link. You
got it?
>> Yeah, I got it. The other m miracle is
the cursing of the barren fig tree. A
stumbling block to many like you. You
stumble. They feel that it is unlike
Jesus. And so someone must have
misunderstood what actually happened
or turned a spoken parable into an acted
miracle or something like that. Some on
the other hand welcome the story because
it shows that Jesus was human enough to
get unreasonably annoyed on occasion. It
appears however that a closer
acquaintance with fig trees would have
prevented such misunderstanding. But
your Muslim friend so he wouldn't know
this. The time of the fig is not yet
says Mark for it was just before
Passover. And Passover takes place
during the spring
season when you have the spring harvest.
For it was just before Passover about
six weeks before the fully formed fig
appears. The fact that Mark adds these
words shows that he knew what he was
talking about. Oh, really? When fig
leaves appear about the end of March,
they are accompanied by a crop of small
knobs called tak by the Arabs, a sort of
foreigner runner of the real figs. These
tak are eaten by peasants and others
when hungry. They chop off before the
real fig is formed, but the leaves
appear uncmpanied by tak. There will be
no figs that year. Golly. So it is
evident to our Lord when he turned aside
to see if there were any of these taken
the fig tree to assuage his hunger for
the time being that the absence of the
tak meant that there would be no figs
when the time of figs come. For all of
its fair folage, it was a fruitless and
a hopeless tree. Did you get your
answer?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Now that's that's clear.
Yeah.
>> Okay. But the better question you should
ask you, my friend, my very sharp
friend,
my very sharp friend, why do you think
he cursed the fig tree?
>> Um,
second.
>> So, you're not a very sharp friend of
mine.
Why do you think he cursed the fig tree?
>> I didn't. Have you not read the chapter?
What does he go? He goes into the temple
and cleanses it, right?
>> Yeah.
And then didn't he then announce that
the temple will be destroyed?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, come on. Why do you think he
cursed the fig tree?
>> Because the Old Testament likens Israel
to a fig tree
right here. Jeremiah 8:13. Mister, read
your Bible.
>> You're all about experience, but lean
learn exesus, dude.
>> I will take
what
>> I'm learning. Yet
>> here Jeremiah 8:13, I will take away
their harvest, declares the Lord. There
will be no grapes on the vine. There
will be no figs on the tree, and their
leaves will wither. What I have given
them will be taken from them. He's
likening Israel to figs and grapes and
vines that are good for nothing but to
be destroyed. Now here, Hosea 9 10- 16.
Here you go. When I found Israel, it was
like finding grapes in the desert. When
I saw your fathers, it was like seeing
the early fruit on the fig tree. It is
the touch. But when they came to
Balpure, they consecrated themselves to
the shameful idol and became as vile as
the thing they loved. If frame is
blighted, their root is withered. They
yield no fruit. Even if they bear
children, I will slay their cherished
offspring. Oh, that's why he crucified
because the fig tree is a picture of
Israel being barren, having no spiritual
fruit. So, what do you do with a tree
that's spiritually dead?
cursed it.
>> You destroy it.
>> Yeah.
>> Oh, how about here? Micah 7:104.
What misery is mine? I am like one who
gathers summer fruit at the gleaning of
the vineyard. There is no cluster of
grapes to eat. None of the early figs
that I crave. Really?
Early figs? Huh? The touch.
All right, here you go. The godly have
been swept away from the land. No one
upright man
man remains. All men lie and wait to
shed blood. Each hunts his brother with
a net. Both hands are skilled in doing
evil. The ruler demands gifts. The judge
accepts bribes. The powerful dictate
what they desire. They all conspire
together. The best of them is like a
brier. The most upright worse than a
thorn hedge. The day your watchman has
come. That day God visits you. Now is
the t time of your confusion because you
are fruitless and barren. I will now
destroy you.
Now, who came looking for early fruit on
the fig tree and didn't find it over
here? Who was it?
Who came looking for figs and couldn't
find it over in Hosea 9?
I can't hear you, man. You're muted.
Let's get this guy out of here. Okay.
Who came looking for figs on the tree?
Who came looking for figs on the tree
right in Hosea 9 and didn't find any?
Come on, guys. Someone tell me, dude.
No one's reading
in Hosea. Who's looking for figs on a
tree? Couldn't find it.
You're asking like you guys are not
certain. God, but hold on. Who came
looking for fruit on the fig tree in
Mark 11 and didn't find any? Jesus.
Oh wow. Hold on. That means Jesus is
assuming the role of God. He comes to
Israel, the fig tree of God, looking for
early fruit, finds none and destroys it.
Also Mark 11 actually is proving that
Jesus made himself out to be God. Now
3:12 all your fortresses talking about
the Assyrians are like fig trees with
their first ripe fruit. When they are
shaken the figs fall into the mouth of
the eater. And here again Jesus likening
Israel
to figs. Luke 13 6-9
here. Then he told this parable. A man
had a fig tree planted in his vineyard
and he went to look for fruit on it but
did not find any. So he said to the man
who took care of the vineyard for three
years now I've been coming to look for
fruit on this fig tree and haven't found
any. Cut it down. Why should it use up
the soil? Sir, the man replied, leave it
alone for one more year and I'll dig
around it and fertilize it. If it bears
fruit next year, fine. If not, then cut
it down. Jesus is likening Israel to a
fig tree that is fruitless and useless,
and he wants to destroy it. But he's
still giving Israel a chance.
Now, do we understand how this actually
backfires and proves Jesus is God?